just happened to you Prophet M said
about you exactly no you don't know
said I know you very extremist I supp
about before
said extremist will be
destroyed mention that always extreme
you Islam talking to me not the camera
being rude I'm not rude okay but you
rude for cutting me you have to let me
finish though that's why I was to C so
might you respectfully of all as long
you allow me to finish go ahead first of
all yeah when you speak I said I didn't
want to be on camera you know come on
what was his name again what was your
name again before what I am going to say
to you is uh
Jack sorry sorry go on going come come
come Jack I
mean you
but you know what was showing this
individual used to be speak Corner
calling us calling us we are
spies you know to begin with so how you
asking
know that's why church say now he left
Islam
completely and this he should be he
should come back to Islam you know why
because what happened to exactly what
prophet Muhammad said about the
the extremist will be destroyed and
mentioned that that that is from The
Prophecy from
the individuals here accusing us that
we're not Muslims and accus us against
of Allah he
became and this is the history of the
the Accord to the Bible yeah kill him
the Bible yes Accord to the Bible kill
him anyway so Accord to the Bible kill
him do you accept that it doesn't say in
the Bible if you leave theion of Mosaic
law you should be killed that's Old
Testament laws so when God said that was
he right or wrong Jesus said he came to
fulfill the law see that's not my
question see the reason I don't want to
speak to you because you're answering my
question
oldest list care Jesus said to go when
God said that Jesus in the answer my
question when God said to was he right
or wrong in the Old Testament I didn't
say it was an Argos book I know it's the
Old Testament the question
was he right or going by the old was he
right or wrong are we still going by the
I'm asking the question was he right or
wrong I'm saying it's the old test I'm
asking you he's so embarrassed am I
embarrassed to say if God was right or
wrong so my question it look the Wes of
sin is De I ask you that my question
when God
said God wanted if that's what God
wanted you have a civil conversation I'm
having allow me to finish my question to
you clearly if in the Bible God said to
kill a poate was he right for saying to
kill a poate the way the sin is dead
that's not my question that was not my
question my question was he right or
wrong that's God's will I didn't tell
you of course God's will I didn't was he
right or wrong that's the question he
was right that was wrong it was right
for tell to kill a PO state that
Jesus Jesus in the old test so okay so
Jesus has bipolar then Jesus bip he said
kill kill poate then don't kill poate
then Kate you live I don't believe in
Jesus according to your belief anyway so
so therefore so therefore let you speak
I so therefore you have no problem for
prate according to the Bible thank you
very much for affirming that you have no
problem if it's old new it is matter
does matter okay Kate you guys kiss a
black stone that's that's brother I kiss
my mother's head out of respect and when
I kiss my mother's head is a worship
mean I'm doing it to please Allah not
mean I worship my my mother's head you
understand so difference between Tak
away your sins your mother no is if I
your mother your if you kiss your mother
have respect respect kissing your mother
takes away your sins yes give you
righteous de and take away your sins
[Music]
yes
Allah don't understand that okay Allah
act of worship you understand what I
mean your mom no no okay when you kiss
do you kiss the the cross no you don't
kiss the cross at okay okay when you
when you when you praise Mary I don't
praise Mary no no is Mary good woman or
bad
woman is Mary good woman or bad woman
she's a good woman she's evil or
righteous she's right are you praising
her now I'm not praising her you need
smoke crack you don't need smoke crack
you stop smoking
crack
even anyone know in English language
when you say someone is righteous and
it's a good person it's a phrase It's a
simple English language doesn't
understand the simple English language
how can I carry on speaking to this
individual I mean my dear brothers and
sisters please tell me how can I have
how can I carry on
conversation he
does understand that when you say
someone a good person it mean prais
unbelievable you know I don't know what
happened to Christian speakers they
don't know English anymore they don't
know no French anymore they don't know
no Arabic anymore they don't know no
Chinese
so I just want to give you an answer I I
just want to give you an answer to your
question wait wait wait wait wait wait I
just want to give you an answer no no no
give you an
answer I was of
time cuz you don't ask the questions can
I answer your question can I answer your
question anyway topic
ex
extremis speak was his name before what
was his name before away I don't know
his
name come here man don't scared anyway
this B is
with we ask to guide Islam you know but
that's what I've been
saying that's
why don't know but it was clear that I
ask is it okay for you to kill him now
no no no it's okay for me to kill him no
that's what to the old no it's not it's
not he went to the Old Testament no it's
not but ACC to the Bible I said it's
okay ACC to the Bible I said that's Old
Testament no okay do you accept old or
do you accept the Old Testament or
notb I'm speaking to
I him
okay K is inherently evil or not
inherently evil no it's not so it
doesn't mean it's not justified so the
the action thank you very much it's not
justified the action is not justified
but it's not evil there's a difference
so the old Covenant is not ideal if you
read for example Jeremiah
3135 you read that God promises a New
Covenant to the Gentiles and to the Jews
which means that he correctly identifies
with the Mosaic law is not sufficient
for all of time it's not a
universal one second which means that
the notion of killing apostates although
is not evil is not now Justified so I
Ami I am not justified in un living a
disbeliever but it's not
immoral there's a distinction okay so
when God ordered the king of for State
at the Moses was he justified yes
talking about so the reason wa wait let
meish let me finish let me finish and
now because the Christian become
liberals that's why you turn away from
the Jesus teaching okay Jesus teaching
Jesus said I me to finish look me to
finish let me finish what because I have
to finish why the Christians scared of
me to finish because why I would expose
them that they turn away from
Christianity even the Christianity they
turn away from it they're becoming more
liberals then okay so in the in the
Bible clearly Jesus the God said to kill
postate so he said that time was
justified however the Jewish people in
our time they still believe in that law
yes do you call Jewish people evil for
believing that law I I think they're yes
evil for denying the new so Jewish
people are evil people for beli no not
believing in the new test I ask you for
not believe New Testament my question my
question so Jewish people are evil
people are evil for not believing in the
New Testament no no no no ask a question
question resp do you believe are evil
for believe
in do you believe okay
for scar to
say
speak he said people are evil for
killing he scared of Jewish people so my
question was to him is Jewish people
evil for believing killing the my
question was not for not beli the new
all right that's why the Christians can
answer my question
okay Heaven and Earth passed away the
temple bres heaven on Earth
over you because something happened
years ago to the
Israelites anymore he's a free man
you're a free
man you
you are you
are you're black you're black man are
you a black
man got
no the
was stop coming to
close me
get it's okay he wants to be close he
wants to no no no brother not this gay
business neither am I don't know about
him him I don't know he likes to come
close to people's faces bro anyway the
point here is the context when the Bible
yeah that's why I believe Isis will the
Bible old old when they K the babies IM
mention the context the context said
said to the
Lord said to Samuel sorry Samuel said to
S the Lord anointed to be king over
Israel yes uhuh now hear the voice of
the Lord Go and Kill Malik why the the
reason is mentioned there because
because the Bible not what was the
reason the
Bible the reason the
Bible in the Old
Testament so so the reason was something
400 years ago something years ago
defend said we
no
[Laughter]
he he said muslim Muslim when when God
when God flooded the earth when God
flooded the
Earth let me let me finish he said the
reason being because the Malik Israel
when they were coming out of Egypt and
that occurred 400 years before
Samu so to clarify it here imagine the
Israelites now or the Jewish people go
to Germany and kill the babies so when
you ask them why you K the babies he
said because Hitler did something with
our forefathers all of us here we say
this is
unjustifiable understand however in the
Bible he said to kill a baby to a baby
speak it to him well you speak it to fre
people in the course of your
diet ask question so the distin
distinction
between allow me to
respond a baby
and God commanded
it already assum
isab ago so here we have is supporter
who justifi he said yes justify the kill
the babies by let
go you need to be careful he's a
Christian by support ISIS come he's
justifying the K of the babies he say
okay to K babies if it was a Muslim who
come but if he a Christian you don't
come he's a
christiany and don't if it was a Muslim
are you resting hypocrisy double
standard anyway conclude on uh so we
conclude
before my dear brothers imagine a Muslim
who standing there just to find the king
of the babies by the time he's about to
leave the park you be arrested and sent
to called
Guan yes but a Christian out there
clearly justifying king of babies
because of why not because it's just
natural disaster no because of the sins
that happened 400 years ago it has
nothing to do with them and that clearly
opposes the teaching which Allah said in
the
Quran Allah does not hold people
accountable for a sins that they never
committed you understand even in Islam
when there is earthquake and children
die children will go to Jen straight
away you understand even the righteous
people will go jenah but these people
they believe that that's what I'm saying
only speak when speak to them about the
Old Testament always emphasize Poss they
to play R say no we don't follow it
anymore so I'm not asking to follow it
or not the question was God right when
he said to kill babies you see so they
have no problem for God K babies they
have no problem for Kate then they try
to say that Islam when he legislated the
law of Kate which is not for everyone
it's for the Islamic country you know
and there's a process you have to go
through but in the Bible even the Jewish
people Layman can do it can carry the
action let's go back to let's go back to
be like come
[Music]
so first of all I wanted to say when you
first spoke to me you was rude and
you yeah you kind let let him land
let he's Landing the aort
he so you approached me with your team
set up and your cameras mics at the
ready
just sorry yeah let let sorry sorry Sor
windy in the end it's too windy in the
end why pushing
me
youlim yes but I still have to be good
to you just with you that's what Islam
teach
us see many people you can blame me
I forgot his name finish Jack Jack all
right what Jack
Jack allow him yet to
his allow don't allow he used to accuse
us look at your
students why you student have to become
just let make a stat go ahead
goet a
of all right let him let him e he's
waiting patiently go on land land I
don't know even though allow to land the
Islam aort I'm joking go casually joking
about farth side very nice so first
thing you said to me when you came you
asked me am I Muslim I I said no and you
said do you know why and as I was about
to answer you interrupted you said yes
it's because Prophet Muhammad said a
load of nonsense no it's not the truth I
haven't finished yet I don't care if you
finished or not spoke the truth so rth
or the truth I'm not going to I'm not
going to allow his nonsense to overpower
the speech of the messenger of Allah for
speech is over spe is above anyone
speech you haven't even heard what I'm
going to say yet CU you haven't shut
up you know when you talk to me talk to
me directly don't look at audience who
you to tell me who what should I do I
talk to the cameras talk to you
me he came and you said you said you
wanted a conversation with me yeah but
you kept getting so why are you having a
conversation with him no because why if
you Tred to tell me you interrupt and
make a stat you ask me a question now
I'm going to again but you ask me a
question though no listen okay go ahead
ask me last
story right very he very sensitive man
is he no because I imagine
de he practice slavery
ISL the Bible
no I'm giving slavery still practicing
morania I'm giving
I'm giving a round of applause because
this man's prediction come
true I made it clear I don't believe in
anything right and I and didn't you say
he's going to randomly bring the
conversation to Christianity to try and
Escape having a conversation 2 minutes
ago that's what he said to about you
no
why he's
mentioning but he comes to me to ask why
I don't believe in Islam and he's
waffling about the Bible he's talking
that's why I'm talking to haven't you
wored that out yet okay okay okay okay
that wasn't for you that it wasn't for
youir even
though I'm not mimal Christian
so being thank you for so tell the guy
to keep quiet and car on talking so
first of all when you first approached
me you made an assumption you knew why I
change beliefs which is wrong you don't
know what I've been doing for the last
several years you don't know what I've
been learning you don't you don't know
about the historical research I've done
understanding theology geopolitical
change over the course of several
centuries instead you assume that
somehow it's something to do with some
Hadith there a load of nonsense so you
came here on a false premise that was
the first thing you did you asked me
then interrupted the answer to give your
own version of an answer see how
disingenuous that actually is and then
you start talking to the audience do do
you actually not see how look besides
from my personal reasons and what I know
besides evidence when someone who is
rational minded and competent when they
see that behavior you really think oh
yeah what an intellectual I really want
to engage with him no they don't that's
why I walked away the first time and
this time I nearly did again cuz you
resorted to the same interrupting
tactics the same camera show come on
look we can have a discussion but speak
to me fairly if you ask me a question
let me answer it don't try and answer
for me with an answer that's got nothing
to do with anything you finished do not
have any respect on that level just a
basic thing that's all I'm asking for
you if you can do that we can have a
conversation but if you're actually
intellectually
incapable people that's he to me sh see
about respect I don't give I don't care
you know look
Allah it's too emotional man it's very
emotional this guy you are because the
guy just greeted me as a Muslim and to
respond to his greetings even though
you're finish your
speech no cuz I was saying to you fin
story now I was saying to you do you
have the intellectual capability to
speak to me not get distracted and not
formed to the camera and you didn't
reply and then went to speak to someone
else I do alhamdulillah very well you
know me very well I've been here for the
last 15 years alhamdulillah been
speaking before you say so let me
clarify something this individual he
think from me using theith of Al who
spoke the truth contradicts what he went
through it doesn't because it doesn't
it's not relevant it doesn't you know
what you know he heard you you know he
listened to you come let's be fair you
know see you see so the mentioned that
the extremist amongst the Muslim they
will be destroyed the scholars explained
what is the meaning of the Hadith that
eventually they will leave Islam because
they go to extreme in Islam which is not
allowed in Islam Islam extremism is not
allowed because Allah refuted the
previous Nation for going beyond the
boundaries when this individual was a
Muslim he used to believe I'm not I was
not a Muslim no he used to yeah you
believe I'm a C I'm you used to believe
I'm you used to believe many things
about me you and this individual he was
calling to sharw which I believe is the
best law for every nation and every
place however however however however
however when we are in a country like
I'm in Britain in this country which
they allow me to stay here they allow
like my family they from here all right
anyway but I have to show them a good
way to give da because Prophet Muhammad
when he sent his companions to ABIA they
were Christians he didn't tell them go
call for Shar and take over the
government no he said go call to Islam
with the accept alhamdulillah you know
so he was following extreme uh set of
Islam and I always tell the people who
have who are upon the same who who are
the same methodology he was upon that if
you carry on you never know you're going
to become proper doing Haram sin openly
or you will leave Islam claiming you
study history you
study and so I'm just I'm I'm
speaking let us land let us go
but you were lying too and I allowed you
to speak but you know when you speak
this is going to happen as well you know
and I hope he can take it now we're
interrupting now interrupting I speak to
you man seriously Li cuz why this
individual was lecturing us about in
summary good manners be
intellectual then he's he's
contradicting himself now while I'm
speaking is cutting me accusing me of
lies anyway so why I would say when I
see him become a C I'm not happy of
course you know but I always
say the prophecy of the messenger of
allaham this this this a Liv example of
the prophecy of
Al he the reason he left Islam going
through history going through her story
My Story the fact is told us the
extremist will be destroyed and this guy
is the living example you can't be
smoking when I'm speaking to you I can
smoke for I like it's a free country you
don't like it no no no it's a free
country but it's not free yeah no it
it's a free it's a free country you can
go and buy any fight anyway I'm leaving
then yeah
you him smoke
he he
become right so I'll address so